it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week that claptrap came from
the moon with Borderlands the pre-sequel
bounding on to last gen consoles and PC
get your moon dance on with low gravity
environments freeze weapons and the all
new playable character claptrap but
there's also Nisha Athena and the
Hyperion to enjoy if you're not a huge
fan of that dancing robot become the
henchman of handsome Jack october
fourteenth but how do you feel about
barbed wire because the evil within is
spilling blood and all sorts of
platforms this week with a pretty gross
group of monsters to take you down
there's a mysterious evil force that's
killed all of your fellow officers even
the one who was only one day to
retirement damn the blood battle begins
October 14 also this week you travel
back to a better-looking hong kong as
wei shen and sleeping dogs definitive
edition relive the fantastic undercover
cop story with upgraded visuals and
gameplay in a more densely populated
area to get you more immersed in this
true-to-life world you look like you
could use a poll fun I'll take to take
out those gang members october
fourteenth pac-man is back in an all-new
3d platformer adventure this week with
new skills and new worlds but with the
same old irritating pack boys go on
betrayus already has a head start i spec
might even have a voice at all there's
only one sound pack management pac-man
and the ghostly adventures 2 comes out
october fourteenth
finally a killer instinct season two
makes its way to xbox one in a gorgeous
world fit for fighting check out Maya
she'll kill you five times before you
hit the ground eight new fighters eight
costumes and sixteen premium accessory
packs are yours along with the classic
games you can get your fight on season
two launches on the 15th for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week
and